we are thrilled about our next guest
actor Ellie Kemper and Zach Cherry they
are teaming up to co-host the Great
American baking show celebrity holiday
so here's how it works celebrity Bakers
they compete to impress judges from the
Great British Bake Off Paul Hollywood
improve Leith the goal is to win the
title Star Baker the contestants include
comedian Chloe Fineman and Super Bowl
winner Marshawn Lynch take a look
or your technical challenge you have
been asked to make a meringue wreath
decorated with sugared berries topped
with mascarpone cream and blueberry
Coulee what what a meringue what well if
you don't know what they're talking
about I'm right there with you but I'm
not baking so you will have two hours on
your marks get set
think that's a lot of pressure right
there Ellie Kemper and Zach Cherry joins
us for their first joint interview they
will also be co-host of the full new
Roku series The Great American baking
show which will Premiere 2023. how you
guys doing very good amazing can we just
say Ellie you look like a piece of
meringue thank you thank you very edible
thank you Zach I'm trying to figure out
how we describe your look today
um a piece of green meringue classic
exactly so you guys look great so Ellie
you're a huge fan of the British uh bake
off
um and what did you feel when you heard
about this new series we I thought I had
won the lottery when they called and
asked about being if I could host
co-host with Zach on the show because it
is such a wonderful show it's light as
air it was a huge Comfort to me during
the pandemic it was it's such an
inspiring uplifting show that like I
just needed a babysitter and wanted to
get on the next plane to go not for me
for my kids and then like yeah no but
both of you seem to be having a good
time it made me think are you Bakers do
you vote I'll let you go first you bake
you're kind I do not no neither do I
Zack I dabble I'm whatever the word for
below an amateur is uh so I made a not
good Baker that's how I would describe
it but so part of what makes the uh the
celebrity special so Charming is it
would appear that the celebrities
themselves not good bakers either yes
well a lot of them had not baked but but
we tried a lot of what they did bake and
it was all pretty good it was yeah we
suspect they presented themselves as oh
we don't know what we're doing cut to
them like feverishly practicing their
craft at home before they got to England
don't you think maybe
the competition is for real though I
mean Marshawn Lynch cracked me up
because every time he spoke he's
hilarious I know he was hilarious and he
actually did pretty good when one of the
comp one of the challenges was to do a
cake that meant something to you and he
did pawpaw's cake number one I just like
the title Papa but you all said that it
actually tasted pretty good though yes I
tried the Papa's lemon cake and it was
delicious yeah from beast mode to yeast
mode there you go
my gosh no he I feel like his his
products were like understated but Prue
and Paul sang the pr saying his Praises
very highly like I think he had the
actual craft done and he was certainly
the best Storyteller about his bakes he
had a lot to say about each thing he
made yep no YouTube guys knew each other
before you said from improv days and we
I worked on Kimmy Schmidt once yeah long
ago yes we were on when we know each
other from Upright Citizens Brigade
theater and and just improv around town
so does improv come into play do you
think in the show I love your tagline
where you say everybody step away from
your bakes I I know that's on improv but
I did like that line did The Improv come
in handy with this you're dealing with
all these different personalities
attempting something for the first time
they say and these are like on the Fly
interviews you walk up they're in a
state of whatever disarray something is
Half Baked and then you launch
definitely yeah it's I mean most of what
we do is just chatting and essentially
improvising with the big acres and
annoying them while they're trying to
complete a very difficult task which I
feel like goes against every Instinct in
your body because you want them to be
able to focus but also your job is to go
and distract them and make small talk
but luckily every
every so so Ellie I I have to say
something you said that you're not a
baker that's what you said at the top of
the show but now according to my little
piece of paper here oh uh you do have
something that you bake when you want to
show off talk about underselling and
over Deliverance
set up earlier
I make something called a gooey butter
cake which is sort of a St Louis I like
the sound I mean Gail the ingredients
are cream cheese butter powdered sugar
and vanilla cake mix like that's it and
it's just it is what it sounds like it's
gooey butter have you ever heard of it I
have yes okay sounds delicious have you
eaten it I've had it in ice cream but
not separately okay oh oh I know what
kind of ice cream it was gooey butter so
next time you come you're gonna bring us
some yeah that's exactly right
the Great American baking show celebrity
holiday is available now to stream on
the Roku Channel